I've got another constant for you Brady
it's a paris' constant one point two two
five six nine pretty to do we could go
on
what is this really this is actually
what I'm writing down here is really 1
plus 1 over 2 cubed plus 1 over 3 cubed
this sum actually appears in in quantum
electrodynamics it's related to the
anomalous magnetic moment of the
electron which is one of the great tests
of QED this number appears in that so it
has physical relevance but that's not
really where we're going to talk about
it today
the reason I want to talk about it is
because it's it's a crazy number in many
ways and not a lot was known about it
for a very long time and it's still not
known about it this goes back to 1644
when Pietro Mengele posed the puzzled
problem of course the basal problem was
the question was not quite this son but
but essentially this son 1 plus a 1 over
2 squared 1 over 3 squared and so on ok
and so to get this enclosed form this
was the problem to get it in closed form
and this was famously solved by Euler in
1735 and he showed that this was equal
to PI squared over 6 now of course Euler
being Euler you know wasn't going to
settle for for just this guy right he
wanted to do this far more generally so
he looked at the general form of these
things a 1 over 2 to the S 1 over 3 to
the S 1 over 4 to the earth and so on
which we recognize as the riemann zeta
function you know one can ask what
values this takes him in me in the
positive integers and this is what we
were was interested in and he was able
to show of course that when you take
even integers so you look at this guy
even values that this took the form of
something rational times pi to the 2m so
of course pi vain transcendental this
guarantees that this number is also
going to be transcendental rate that was
the for the even positions what about
the odd ok the things like these are to
the 2 n plus 1 and which of course this
guy which is of course
pretty constant is at the value three
what about this is this rational is this
transcendental what what is it boy
looking like it out or look couldn't do
it and nobody knew for hundreds of years
what was going on with this moment till
this mathematician came along a kind of
maverick mathematician a good
mathematician but not not a great
mathematician a guy called Roger Avary
actually solved this problem and after
he's quite an interesting character
actually his friends he was a very
political though politically active he
was a prisoner of war in the Second
World War and he some had quite a dry
sense of humor actually later on he was
a member of the the French Resistance at
one point he was actually stopped by the
Gestapo because he was carrying an
object with with a long thin object
which wrapped in newspaper and the
Gestapo said to him is what are you
carrying there is it gone and he said no
it's a leg and it was a leg it was it
was his friend for prosthetic leg but he
was going to get fixed so he was there
but you know this was biggest a foe
who's Mexican right so he was pushing
his look somewhat anyway this sort of
says a humor this this sort of Clinton
of Maverick style actually carried
through let's fast-forward to 1978
he's coming towards the end of his
career there's this he's a good
mathematician but not a great one and he
gives a seminar about the value of this
this Zita function at three okay and
whether it's rational which hadn't been
in which the great Euler had not be
himself and not being able to solve
anyway after he says he solved it okay
it is irrational and he can prove it so
he starts his and everyone's a bit
skeptical okay so he starts his seminar
and the first thing he writes down is
the following
doesn't really matter details of that
don't matter the point is nobody in the
audience has ever seen this formula
before okay it's not being proven
nothing so they immediately ask you know
where where did no one see this before
where did they find it so the way to
define this formula and he says he
replies are they growing my garden okay
so everybody's getting look gets annoyed
at this point people start to leave and
like you know it was furious and then
while this is all going on people are
leaving some guy at the backs got a
programmable car
calculator and managers can verify this
so at least the accuracy of the
calculator and then you know that the
thoughts going on eat here interrupts
and says and announces this which point
everyone sits up and starts paying
attention and it turns out that after he
has solved this hundreds of years old
problem and he proves that it is indeed
irrational and if course it is fabulous
it sort of shook maps at the time people
started to try to to use it to then
start to ask questions about the other
odd values you know zero five zero zero
seven and so on and they try to use the
same method and all methods like that
have so far failed interesting enough
and so this still not know whether those
guys are a rational or not but three we
create three is definitely irrational
but it's not known whether it's
transcendental what is known about the
other odd ones is that there are an
infinite number of irrational ones but
we don't know which one they are
it's even known that one over Z two five
three two seven zero nine and Zeta
eleven but one of these is irrational we
don't know which one so it's so little
known about it and it's sort of I think
it's a fabulous number so come back to a
furry I did a shout-out on Twitter I ask
people to send in three randomly chose
and positive integers and the reason I
did that was cuz I wanted to estimate
after is constant now I'm a bit lazy so
I didn't go to all three cotton loads
and some people football them a little
bit hard to manipulate as well there's
quite some quite entertaining comments
about how you can't choose that random
numbers from just a hundred and forty
characters and so on and so forth but
anyway I did go through someone I went
through quite a few I have a list here
what I did was I went through those
numbers and I checked whether the
combinations were co-prime so in other
words I asked what was their greatest
common divisor of the three numbers and
if that greatest common divisor was want
then there co-prime if it was something
of a higher than one then they're not
going quite so I just went through and I
checked them all all the different
combinations so let me do I've gotta
count this now really I haven't haven't
check this I didn't check that and all
that the estimate came out right so this
is real times the election stuff so
anyway the number that occurred prime
let's just let's just count them okay so
here's my list so that's one all the
ticks are co-prime okay these normal
tweeted these are all the tweets not all
things I do is just too many so I had to
stop at some point it's a lot of them
okay so these are all the tweeters
so anyway okay so if they're ticked
there then there and then there co-prime
complete sensing code prime combination
so one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen at 38 39 40 41 42 43 44
45 equal to 69 70 71 72
so there's 72 of those came in as Cobra
and copn combinations some people
didn't send in co-prime combinations
what I've written down here they are the
greatest common divisors that they had
so we'll just count how many of those
there were one two three four five
fourteen fifteen all right let me cine
okay so that's a toll over it was 87 in
total right okay now I claim that this
is the road of truth now though this is
going to work there 87 divided by the
number of coasters total and red divided
by the co prime number I see what number
excuse laughs oh boy
for food it's not bad not bad
is that good I think it's pretty close
roughly that I'm very happy that I split
okay good yeah and I'm sure if I dug
through all of them this has got more
and more accurate right okay how why I
suppose we had s numbers that's what's
the probability that any given note so
we got some prime number P what's the
air what's the probability that any
given you pick a random number that it's
divisible by P it's 1 over P if I've got
ash numbers what's the probability that
they're all divisible by P well that's
going to be 1 over P to the S
what's the probability that at least one
of those s numbers is not divisible by P
that's one minus one of the PPS so they
ask whether if I've got s numbers
whether they're the probability that
their lowest common divisor is 1 I the
basis no private or the prime numbers
that the order divides them all then I
just have to click the product of this
number over all the primes so that's the
product over the primes of 1 minus 1
over P to the S and now our friend Euler
comes back right because all a toilet
you can always like Euler Euler showed
that the theta function was the product
over the primes 1 minus 1 over P to the
S to the minus 1 so this is 1 over Zeta
of s ok so this means you've got a 1 in
theta s chance of finding a co-prime
combination okay so for 3 I've got three
numbers the chances of finding a copn
combination are 1 and Z 2 3 that's why
it worked
make sense
[Music]
thanks for watching this video if you'd
like to show a bit more support to
numberphile you can support us on
patreon the address is on the screen and
in the video description that support
helps us make even more and better
videos and we try to make it worth our
patrons while by adding a few extra bits
and pieces for them on our patreon page
but as always the best support you can
give us is to be subscribed to
numberphile and keep watching we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]